juste avant je suis monsieur rendu danse
dans l'ascenseur d'un centre commercial
et on a piégé l'ascenseur l'ascenseur se
bloque un moment forcément vous appelez
le dépannage et quand le dépannage c'est
moi à merde c'est compliqué regardez
m
la patinoire
[Musique]
oui
allô allô on n'évoquait pas d'un
identité de la personne qui me plaît
notre tout mal pourquoi
makoto prénom en fait d'un coup de c'est
le prénom
bien que localisée rauseo plait merci
c'est pas moi qui les ai entendu que les
enseignants comment savoir dans quel but
à débloquer dans ses travers en appel a
mené par téléphone omar alaoui
significatif aux biens et aux espaces
piétons avec moi parce que je vais venir
il ya des claques qui vont tomber un
bien là mais il va voir et gogo ville tu
vas te calmes et vous appuyez sur un
cloche un clash attendait
sa déco ce que je te dis ni les deux là
les deux bouts fora et ont écouté la
forêt appuyés sur 0,1 cloche zéro passe
un truc là
l'ancien du tout là c'est normal
monsieur foot s'est pas enlevé sac à dos
a annoncé gênant si vous mettez le
parterre le pull aussi le plus nanterre
si je veux pas manger des grosses
claques pour moi n'est pas laid back
j'adore les bas lui même s'est contenté
cette fois je la prenais un petit
quelque chose et j'en témoigne chansons
jouées en tout de suite parce que je
voulais bien où nous la porte s'il te
plaît vous on va te casser les dents
chanter à cet effort là faire un effort
et vous si vous dites on est deux gros
bouffons vous dépendez deux gros
bouffons steuplé ouvre la porte grand
chef c'est bon c'est en gros bouffons
ouvre la porte blanche est jamais eu de
clash quitte à réduire le poids pour
l'ascenseur toujours le pied je sors
c'est sauter
[Musique]
c'est moi bon alors en 3d c'est bon le
rapport cite hacker a reconnu son
travail et nous a tous ces gestes offre
un cadeau dauphin royal saint père est
allé de bouffon la salle a battu mais
klein qui passe à la télé sur le quai 0e
bonjour tête de ma mère je voyais à
s'est retrouvé que je suis cyril hanouna
c
je vais pas mourir regagner moscou
[Musique]
je fais attention
7,5 d'accor
[Applaudissements]
mais on a et on n'a aucune valeur et les
deux garçons les a vraiment envoyer en
vacances et sur les choix qui sont dans
le public qu'est ce qu'ils sont et ce
qu'ils peuvent lever la main et ils sont
partis directement à marrakech en
vacances et le petit garçon est venu
avec moi directement sur tp mais vous
allez voir il ya un autre ascenseur tout
à l'heure on est tombé sur deux clients
sans déconner jamais vu ça de ma vie
j'en ai pleuré de rire